- On this episode I talk about Periscope,
what's my favorite airport,
and how do I get over being young?
(bouncy music)
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and you're listening and watching
to The #AskGaryVee Show, episode 8-O.
I'm gonna give a big shout out
to my boy Wayne Chrebet,
classic all time New York Jet.
Hustler, you know, 11th
man on the depth chart,
went all the way up to getting
his number retired last year.
Wayne, big shout out, he wore number 80,
this is episode number 80, let's get into
the show.
- [Voiceover] Abby
asks, "As a 24 year old,
"how can I turn a possible disadvantage
"like being young, into an advantage
"as a speaker and a coach?"
- Abby, this is a great question,
and first of all, we waited a long time
to answer this right.
She's been posting this on
the Gram for awhile, India,
I'm talking to you?
- [India] Long time.
- Long time.
So, first of all, really appreciate
the hustle and the perseverance.
Actually, let's interrupt the show
and tell you how you can ask a question
on The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey, I'm Gary Vaynerchuk,
and you're watching
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Tim, that's a great question.
Paul, that's a great question.
Matt, this is a great question.
(light music)
Abby, you know, it's funny.
I love your hustle and
perseverance so much,
but I'm gonna zing and zang
a little bit on this answer
because I am really tired of 21, 19,
22, 24 year olds wanting to be
speaker and coaches about things
that they are not able
to speak and coach about
because they don't have the experience.
You're right, it is a disadvantage.
It's very hard for me to want to listen,
or pay you for business advice
when you've never built a business.
And by the way, you don't have to be 24,
you could be 39 and try
to sell business advice,
when you've never sold a business.
Now, that's me making a
leap and an assumption
that that's what you want to talk about.
If you want to talk about the perspective
of a millennial on how to use social media
because you are one, cool.
If you want to talk about
the things you've learned,
you know, in whatever genre.
If you've been making
music since you were 13,
and you're 24, that's an 11 year career,
but the truth is you can only talk about,
and demand and command
attention and respect
around something you've
actually accomplished.
Just saying that you're
a coach and a speaker
doesn't mean you are one because
you just said you are one.
You've got to earn the
credit to be able to do it.
Now look, do I believe that you can be
a football coach without playing football?
Yes, but we've hit on this before.
When you look at the
coaches that were coaches
that, you know, didn't play football,
most of them played college football,
maybe they didn't get to the pros.
Most of them, if they
didn't play football,
at least, at bare minimum,
played high school football competitively,
and then had a father normally
who was a coach, or was
within the organization
of a major sports franchise.
I mean, you've got to put in the work,
and so you know, the reason
there's a disadvantage
of being 24 and getting
people to listen to you
is cause they're right.
Now, there's anomalies, maybe you were 17
and you built a huge
business and sold it at 21.
The age is not the variable, you know,
I feel like I did a lot by 24.
I could walk onto stage and say,
"Hey guys, in the last 24 months,
"since I was 22, and I took
over my dad's business,
"I've taken it in the last 24 months
"from 3 to 15 million dollars.
"Here's how I did it."
That's some credibility,
that's some chops,
but I couldn't have at that point say,
"Let me talk to you about HR as a leader."
Only 24 months of that experience,
only so much value compared
to when I do it now
of having two decades of doing it.
So you know, it's a
disadvantage for a purpose,
right, for a reason.
If you're an anomaly, radical,
but if you're not, you need to respect
that people are not idiots.
- [Voiceover] Hans
asks, "What do you think
"about the recent Twitter
acquisition of Periscope?"
- Hans, this is a tremendous question.
As we are filming this right now,
so for everybody who's listening,
I'm gonna have DRock
show Staphon right now,
who's actually filming us and Meerkatting.
Staphon, flip over the screen,
show the camera, flip over your screen.
Zoom in DRock, no, no,
flip, don't look at you.
Show the, there we go, thank you.
Yeah, so you know, right now we are,
we're Meerkatting, I don't
know if you know that,
but that's an actual animal,
you can go back to me.
I think if I was Meerkat,
I'd be very concerned.
You know, obviously we're all
enjoying the Kat quite a bit,
live streaming, phone to phone,
peer to peer is clearly here,
but if I was Meerkat, I would be concerned
about this acquisition because clearly
if it's got the same functionality,
which is what it's rumored to have,
I haven't seen it yet, but
I will probably test it out
this weekend if I get a chance,
at South by Southwest.
Oh, which reminds me, if you're
goin' to South by Southwest,
please check out my talk, Saturday
at three PM, Austin time.
I think that I'd be concerned,
and I think that I'm definitely
gonna check it out because I should,
and because it's gonna be integrated
probably natively into the Twitter app.
So, it will be interesting
to see this play out
if it's gonna be a fast move
by Twitter to integrate.
We've seen this before, you know,
I remember people saying, "Oh
Facebook's doing check ins,
"Foursquare's dead."
And it didn't happen because it wasn't
native to the product, but I do think
this functionality clearly,
cause Meerkat's built
on top of Twitter, from the sign in,
from the push outs, from the engagement,
when people are commenting right now,
it's showing up on Twitter.
This is deeply integrated into Twitter,
and thus will be interesting
to watch what happens here.
I absolutely plan on using it.
I see a scenario where
this is really detrimental
to Meerkat, I see a scenario where
Twitter tries to see if both can survive.
I don't know, it'll be
interesting to watch,
but the acquisition has
definitely caught my attention.
I'm paying very close attention,
and I plan on testing out the product
as soon as possible so I can make
my judgements on differences.
- [Voiceover] Samantha asks,
"How do your right hooks
"differ for a free service
versus a paid one?"
- When you're throw the
right hook that's free
I get excited because
there's less friction,
and it feels like I'm gonna really be able
to land that right hook.
The problem is, there's a
really funny thing about free.
Free creates a scenario where people value
it for what it's been put out.
It's really interesting.
I think that a lot of people who watch
this show value it quite a bit.
I think that the 10% left,
if I started charging
four bucks an episode,
or two bucks an episode,
the you know, actually you know what,
that's gonna be the question of the day.
And I know this is a tough question,
and by the way, I will
not be charging for this,
so don't worry, don't hedge and say zero,
I don't have any plans on it.
But if I was, what would you pay
to watch an episode of
The #AskGaryVee Show?
And yeah that's the real question.
And clearly, I expect most
of the comments to be zero,
or no, because I respect that there's
so much content out
there, but I do believe
that my content is better
than a substantial amount
of content out there in the world.
Especially when it talks about
new platforms, business,
running businesses,
leadership, entrepreneurship,
start up, tech culture.
So, I do think that we'll
see a surprising number,
and I'm sure you're
probably getting answers
right now in Meerkat,
so Staphon, feel free
to not shout it out, cause
I want to be surprised.
But I do think that
it's really funny to me
to think about the 10% of
you that I would expect
to pay for it that if you
were paying four bucks for it
you'd actually value the show more.
It's really quite interesting psychology.
So, how do I act differently?
One, when I throw right
hooks, for example,
when I tweet out later
today that episode 80 is up.
You know, I expect to
land more than saying,
"Episode 80 is up, pay
me three dollars Snapcash
"if you want to watch it."
You know, I have a little less angst
of the conversion because I know
that there's no friction financially,
which is one, besides time,
finance is the friction.
And so, I think it's got a
totally different cadence,
different expectation,
different pressure hold.
I think it's easier.
- Hey Gary, answer my question.
By the way, go Giants.
- [Voiceover] Ryan asks,
"I work for a company
"that makes animated explainer
videos for businesses.
"Is Google pay per click the best option
"for B to B companies like us?"
- Ryan, great question.
Really excited about baseball right now.
I'd love to get your
comment in the sections
about Brandon Belt, very much on my radar
to draft this year on fantasy baseball.
Hopefully nobody in the Vayner 20 man
fantasy baseball league
is listening or watching,
but I know Bobby Glen watches.
So, I'm a little upset
now that he has optics
into what I'm doing, though I could
be throwing him a curve ball.
Listen, Google pay per
click is tremendous,
but I also think that Linkedin ads
have tremendous upside for you.
Also, Linkedin creative,
meaning putting out
blog posts on Linkedin, and then having
a call to action at the bottom
I think could actually
work for you quite a bit
cause the B to B mentality within Linkedin
is so over the top, it's
the context of the room.
So, I'm a big fan of putting out content
now that everybody can blog on Linkedin,
and then maybe use that content
on your email newsletter, on your website,
on other places where you have
a little bit of a base to
create some awareness around it.
I'm a big fan of that.
I actually think you can get stunningly,
stunning Hail Mary upside
on both Pinterest and Instagram.
I think Pinterest's ad product
that we'll probably see roll out this year
has a chance to really matter for you
if you're actually targeting people
in a business world that
could actually buy this,
but yeah I would say Google,
I would say content.
I would say go and reach
out to any B to B platforms.
Podcasts, some blogs that
speak to the audience
that you're trying to reach and see if
your CEO or creative
director can be a guest
contributor, or interviewed on there
because that exposure I think actually
can convert for you,
maybe not at the scale
that you can get from a PPC Google world.
I also think you can target people
by their office, you
know by where they work
on Facebook dark posts
that I think you could get
some really great results there.
Especially if you upload
some of the native videos
that you actually create
in native Facebook form,
I think you can actually get
some interesting results there.
So, do I think Google PPC
still wins the day for you?
I think it's clearly gonna
be one of the three winners.
I think Facebook dark posts,
and I think Linkedin ads
supported by Linkedin creative
play and can compete at that level.
So, that's where I would focus.
- [Voiceover] CJ asks, "What's
your favorite airport?"
- CJ, this is a great question.
My favorite airports are
always like small ones
like in Des Moines, or like,
you know, which I've been to.
Or you know, where is that,
you know, South something.
Somewhere in Greenville, South Carolina.
You know, Montana, some
of the places I've done,
Arkansas, some of the stuff I've done,
Chattanooga, Tennessee.
You know, the airports you walk in,
oh when we had Green Mountain Coffee
as a client, the Vermont airport.
I mean, you know, the airports
that you could literally roll up to
and be at your gate within,
I don't know, four minutes,
with no pre-check.
You know, I like those places.
I also clearly feel very, I mean,
Newark, JFK, and Laguardia have,
and in some weird way
SFO, I know everything
about LAX, SFO, LGA, JFK, and Newark.
I know those airports, I
probably know the nuances
of those airports better than I know
the office of VaynerMedia.
They've become my home.
Big shout out to Johnny at LGA.
I mean, these people
have become my friends.
It's really quite sad,
like I almost feel like
they're breaking TSA rules,
like they don't even need
to check my ID, they're like, "Hey Gary."
I'm like, "Hey."
You know, like it's, you know,
so I, the really sad
answer to this question,
the actual real authentic
sad answer to this question
is all of them.
The coziness that I feel at an airport
is disturbing at best.
That's it.
- [India] Yeah, that's everything.
- Cool, let's do one more added question.
I know there's a delay,
but we'll sit here and jam.
Let's film Staphon,
actually let this all
roll DRock, no editing.
We're gonna ask a Meerkat question.
Staphon, as soon as you
see one that you like,
cause I know there's a delay,
so they'll pop up in a second.
Pop, poppin' away.
And you can just ask one.
So, there's no awkward
silence, you can look at me
and I can just talk
about something random.
Darrelle Revis (laughs).
So goddamn happy.
So, South by Southwest,
my seventh or eighth year,
heading down in a couple of hours.
Hopefully, you know,
please hit me up on Twitter
if you're down there, I'm trying
to do some random meet ups.
And definitely come and check out my talk,
I will stick around after
and like selfie it up.
Got anything?
- [Staphon] Somebody
asks, "What does it take
"to work at VaynerMedia?"
- What does it take to
work at VaynerMedia?
That's a good question, thanks Meerkat.
- [DRock] Who was it?
- He doesn't know.
That's why he said
somebody, or you got it?
It scrolls.
- [Staphon] Yeah, at, Jesus Christ,
now everybody's asking.
- Yeah, it's over, sorry
if you asked this question.
No IP love.
You know, I think it takes
a million different things
depending on what the job is.
It's about the right job
for the right person.
So, the answer is, anybody
probably could work
at Vayner at some level, they just have
to have self awareness if
they are a project manager,
or a creative director,
account sup., a CM,
but it definitely takes, I think the more
interesting question is: What does it take
to win at VaynerMedia?
Right, so like getting
in, like we've had plenty
of winners and losers get in.
How to win here I think is a fine balance
of one, having empathy and self awareness,
and respecting the others around you.
Having patience, I think a lot of people
lose within the first six,
12, 18 months at Vayner
because they're just not
playing the long game,
and they either want a
raise, or a promotion,
or have the audacity of
like thinking they're better
than they are, but while equally,
this is back to pulling
in both directions,
I want that bravado and confidence,
and all those things.
So, I think it's about making networks,
having relationships,
having self awareness,
having patience, over communication.
You know, like what if this
machine is doing bad by you,
I respect that. We're not perfect.
I want to be there for
you, so are you speaking
to Minnie in HR, or me,
or AJ, or your leaders
within your organization, or
at least 30 to 50 people here
that have been here for
a year to three years
that are really the foundation
of the ethos of the company.
So you know, I think there's
a lot of different things
that it takes, but it
definitely takes hard work,
it definitely takes smarts,
but what trumps status, it takes heart.
- [India] I found who asked the question.
- You did, India?
- [India] Laz Alberto.
- Laz Alberto, cool, great job.
- [India] Yay Laz.
- Hey Laz, oh great you searched, yeah.
Great job India, I'm proud of you.
You keep asking questions,
India will keep finding them.
(laughing)
By the way, do you see my new pants?
These are nice new pants.
Do you like them?
They're kinda like, they're
not really burgundy.
- [Staphon] They're like a burnt orange.
- Yeah, like a burnt, well
they're not orange, Staphon.
- We already have like.
- [DRock] They're maroon.
- Yeah, they're maroon, but like,
like they're like, I don't know, anyway.
I mean, and the fact that
the Meerkat caught it,
please tweet out that
DRock (bleeps) it up.
Actually, I'm pissed it
wasn't part of the show,
cause that would've got him mad,
but I would've loved the real shit.
Alright.
(mumbling)
Some a month, some per episode.
I wonder, no just kidding, alright.
Give me that.
Let's reverse, hey guys.
Confidence is key, cockiness is the lock
that can open any door, or the difference.
Hey everybody, how are you?
Laz said hey to India, that's nice.
- [India] Hey Laz.
- Hey Laz.
They're not chatting anymore?
"Where's the question,"
oh I didn't do a question,
yeah I did a question of the
day in the episode, yeah.
"Hey, hey, hey, DRock is awesome."
This is crap. DRock, what do you think?
Tim said that.
- [DRock] Thank you Tim, I appreciate you.
- "Hey India, from India.
I'm hustling in Russia, (mumbles)."
"Hey India from India,"
I gotta figure that out.
Jace from Puerto Rico, love it.
There was a question of the day guys,
it was intermingled, you didn't watch?
"This is nuts, thanks for
the show," you got it.
"Great show, thank you,"
the beard is coming in.
Right, you guys didn't know I could grow
a beard like this, huh.
- [Voiceover] No, I have
a video where you had it.
- Oh right, the playoff
beard, yeah, it grows in.
"Good day," very nice.
The beard, I am preparing
for Ryan Fitzpatrick,
my new quarterback.
"Like you Sonic reference
a few shows," it chops off.
"Team pizza or team burrito?"
Neither, Muscle Mike wouldn't
let me eat, like eating either.
"Do you think Meerkat
could do a dating version?"
It chops off, yeah, the answer's yes.
I'm sure there's plenty
of interest (mumbles).
- [DRock] Do you have your WiFi on?
- What's up?
I have my WiFi on.
"Love that we caught
it live, epic episode."
Thank you Richard.
"Do you feel Meerkat is
starting to explode?"
Jayden, I think it's
clearly gaining traction.
It's still nerded out,
when you get the first
couple big celebrities to do it,
and we have like, you know I'm pumped
that 517 of you want to jump in here,
but like when there's 14...
When you get one of these
GrapeStory celebrities
that has like 44,000 on cause
it's all teenage girl culture.
You know, it'll be interesting.
"Why don't you watch your own videos?
"Ego or time?"
John, you know time. I don't know if ego.
I don't know if I'm trying to
be like cooler than myself.
Is this a battle between me and myself?
(laughing)
I don't watch my own videos
because I know what I fuckin' did.
Like, I watched it already.
Rosie, "Thanks for the beard love."
Thank you.
A lot of people asking me
not to get rid of the beard.
It's really, what do you think India?
You don't like the beard,
or you like the beard?
- [India] I like it.
- Is that like a weird question?
Did I put you in a weird spot there?
- [India] Maybe, that's fine.
- I'm sorry about that.
(laughing)
"The new Ustream Q and A?"
Yeah Luke, this definitely
has the potential to do.
So Luke has been with me for a long time.
We used to do Ustream Q
and A's like it was our job
back in like '07, '08, '09.
So, this is super fun.
"What's your favorite red wine right now?"
Rosie, there's a Malbec that Wine Library
is going to offer in two weeks.
If you go to WineLibrary.com right now,
we have a new popup that can sign you up
for the email list, you should sign up
because in two Wednesdays
one of my favorite wines
of all time for $30, $40
is this Argentinian Malbec
that blew me away and we're gonna
do it for 19.99 by the case,
or maybe even by the bottle,
Brandon's debating
that, but blows me away.
"Social beards," yeah I've
been seeing him hit me up.
What are social beards?
What is joining social beards?
(mumbles) I've seen him hit me up on that.
Does that mean he wants me to follow them?
- [India] There's a social
beard network called Bristlr.
- I don't know how long I'm gonna.
I feel like I'm not gonna keep the beard,
I'm gonna do like a weird.
I think I'm gonna do
like, I'm gonna do yeah,
I'm gonna do a whole handlebars thing.
- [Staphon] Oh please do it.
- You want me to do it.
I think I'm gonna do it.
I think I'm gonna go.
I did it once on a Spanish wine trip
for 17 days, when I came home
Lizzie like lost her mind.
Like we were just together
for like two years,
she opened the door, she's like,
I hadn't seen her for 17, the
longest time we were apart,
and you know, early love, you know.
Opens the door and she's like (screams).
It was awesome.
I might just keep the under,
like I might just shave everything
here and just keep this.
Yeah.
You want the handles.
Sapola, you can do,
what can you do for me?
Sapola, here's something
you can do for me.
I want all 535 people who
are watching this right now
to go on Stitcher or ITunes
and follow the podcast
and leave a review to the podcast.
I need that umph because I'm trying to,
you know for me, when
you're putting out content,
people discovering your
content is so important.
So, you guys as a community getting,
you know, Twitter's gotten so noisy
that you know people
giving me love on Twitter
is nice, but blog posts
or podcast reviews,
or Instagram is huge,
like taking a screenshot
of this right, oh you know
what would be awesome?
Actually, this is a fun social.
Here's a right hook and a fuckin' half.
Taking a screenshot of this right now.
So, I'm actually gonna
wait a second and be like.
No, I'm not, taking a
screenshot of this right now,
and then putting out an Instaphoto
and giving me some love, that would be,
that is like a hardcore right hook ask,
but would be a big deal for me
because really I'm obsessed with...
When you're putting out content,
you're looking for distribution.
I believe that humans and your fans
are the biggest distribution.
I believe that my fans over index
with giving me love on Twitter.
I believe the attention graph
on Twitter is getting hurt.
So, I need to siphon that into
the places that matter to me right now
which is Stitcher, and you know,
and iTunes for the podcast,
because I want to build up
the podcast a little bit.
It's definitely Instagram.
So, that would really, really,
really mean a lot to me.
Screenshot of this, and then my handle
@GaryVee on Instagram,
and you know just a like
right hook to the community.
Listen, I feel like it's a big right hook,
you don't have to do it, but
that would be a huge deal.
I would be really, really happy.
"DRock fucked up," Chris.
Chris is an Olympian.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Yeah, he's fuckin' awesome.
(mumbles) "It would be really badass
"if you reviewed my podcast:
"Where to hunt Wisconsin podcast."
That's awesome.
(mumbles) I don't want to bullshit you,
I'm barely catching up with my email,
so the chances of me actually listening
to the podcast and then
being able to review it,
because I would never
review it without watching.
I feel that's not
authentic, in the same way
I would never want anybody
here to take a screenshot
and post in on their
Insta, or leave a review
if they don't comfortable so.
"Pro tip for South by."
Daniel, don't get caught up
in too many scheduling things.
The serendipity has all the action.
Serendipity has all the action.
Rosie, thanks for screenshot.
"Who's your favorite YouTuber and why?"
Again, I don't consume, I put out content,
I don't consume it, I
consume your content.
In the time that most
of you, it's not a dis,
most of everybody would
spend maybe these 10 minutes
maybe watching something they like
or listening to something, or reading.
Like things that I think I
could've seen myself doing
if I didn't go rogue,
like reading Grantland
for 10 minutes right
now, or you know like.
What I'm doing is I'd rather give back
to my community right now,
and jam with you guys, right.
So, my consumption has
been converted into my interaction.
Yeah, there it is, that's what it is.
My consumption is my interaction.
You know, you got it?
- [India] I gotta right that out.
- Yeah, my consumption, like
why I don't consume media
it's because all those extra minutes
are going into answering people,
and you know what's,
I want to go hardcore.
Let's take a bunch of the,
like I don't think people
recognize how much email I get
of like life story, and
then I have to read it,
and then respond, and we'll X
out people's names and such,
and then we'll use the generic ones like,
"Hey, like how do I crush it?"
You know, but like, you know like.
Yeah, you know that's what it is.
My, that's my consumption.
So, I don't consume anything.
"Do you still lift?"
Hell yeah.
Like it's startin' to happen for me.
But I'm gonna wait, I'm
gonna wait another year.
When it's, I mean, I finally like
have something here, it's crazy.
"Instagram's easy ask, consider it done."
Thank you so much the life of Nadia.
I love that, thank you so much.
Actually, you know what, what?
Jason from China.
- [India] You got a really funny email
from Jason from China.
Oh yeah.
- [India] He lost a lot of weight.
- [Staphon] He lost a lot of weight.
- [India] He just wanted
you to know, I guess.
- That's awesome, I
need to check that out.
"When are you gonna hit
up Bayway Liquor next?"
Bayway, that's so funny, I've known
the people that own that
store my whole life.
Like, do you think I own Bayway Liquors?
Cause I don't, but Wine
Libary's 15 minutes from Bayway,
and I love those guys.
I hope they're doin' well.
"Instagram pic added, and tagged."
You know what I'm gonna do?
"I'm missing class for this."
That's the best investment
you've ever made.
Here's my right hook.
Holy crap he lost a ton of weight!
- [India] Yeah.
- Good for him, he looks great.
- Shit.
See, this is what pisses me off.
I lost 20 pounds and nobody even knows.
- [India] Everyone knows.
- Alright, alright (mumbles).
Thank you for delivering,
alright, I gotta get out of here.
Romy, you waiting for me?
Alright, I gotta get Romy,
she's been waiting forever.
See ya!